but
at the same time you've said that quote
i don't believe there's pleasure in life
i believe there's only a relief from
pain we have to suffer to be on top
so isn't there something to just the
suffering in itself
just doing really difficult [ __ ] just to
get to the top
to explain that and so people can relate
to it because not everybody's a fighter
i think the best example i can
gives is let's say you're you haven't
eat for a long time
and you're you're craving right so
you're suffering
and then when it's time to eat finally
you're about to eat your favorite dish
it's going to taste so much better so
that's why i believe
there is always a some sort of sacrifice
before the pleasure and the more
sacrifice you do
like they say in fighting the bigger the
risk
bigger is the reward and i feel that's
that's how it is
for me yeah i feel that with uh i've
started fasting a little bit
in the past couple of years and uh
there's nothing as amazing
as a delicious meal or anything actually
anything any food
when you haven't eaten for several days
it's
it's kind of incredible uh it's not
incred it's not incredible in this
simple way of
finally i get to eat it's you get to
truly experience
the the beauty of of what it is to be
alive
like that little piece of food you see
all the flavors
you you you feel just the experience of
it
is uh ultimately of gratitude of how
awesome it is to be alive
but when you eat many times a day and
you're pigging out and
you don't get to experience that and
it's fascinating it's
really like fasting is one of the most
accessible
things for people i think to experience
that kind of
uh pairing of hardship to pleasure
i agree and in my case it changed my
life
on a good good way i cannot recommend it
to people because everybody is different
but after my uh to to fight michael
bisping my last fight
was against uh the champion in the
heavier
weight class that i used to compete at
so
i thought that if i would gain weight
it would increase my performance yeah
and i struggled a lot to gain weight i
gained a little
about eight to 10 10 pounds normally i
walk around 185 pounds and for that
fight i was walking around 195
however i forced myself to eat like six
times a day i was
on a very strict diet
and i didn't feel it didn't feel right
to me because
i feel like i i was carrying like a
little bit like i was carrying a bag
on my shoulder and
i think it was a bad idea for me because
when i
did the weight the weigh-in and i i
go went on a scale at 185 i couldn't go
back to my initial weight that was
180 195 that i worked so hard for
several months
to get there so i was 190 pounds
but i couldn't get back and the morning
of the fight i i
i got i got sick i had like we didn't
know what
what it wasn't the beginning because
in order to know to find out what it was
i needed to do what they call a
colonoscopy they put a camera inside of
you and
to do that they give you um
something that makes that empty you and
i was trying to gain
weight not to lose weight so i i told
myself
i'm gonna wait after the fight whatever
it is
because it was pretty bad it was blood
and i i didn't know what i was i was
very concerned concerned i thought i had
maybe cancer i was freaking out
so i said i'm gonna do that fight and
then after right away i'm gonna make a
checkup
so i did the fight everything went well
i won the fight i went back home i did
the colonoscopy and i got diagnosed with
ulcer colitis then i got on very severe
medication
to get better and i'm not a big fan of
medication i was
trying to look for more natural way to
to to get better and i found out about
fasting
and um it really changed my life i met
dr
jason fong who's one of the
one i'm one of the world authority of of
fasting
he treat diabetes patient with fasting
and he gave me a program of fasting and
it really changed my life
you